nabila est arrivé le 24 septembre 2014
regardez sa première intervention dans
tpm paix regarde vous êtes stressé ou
pas franchement j'ai l'impression que je
vais je vais rentrer je fais ma rentrée
la haye c'est vrai m me crever savais
que si ça fait plaisir
c'est la première fois qu'on dit que
j'ai une tête de prof d'histoire-géo va
s'apaiser
[Applaudissements]
alors à nabila qui nous a décidés y en a
un petit tweet
regardez voilà merci et ben voilà on l'a
pas elle a mis les 81 pc les nabis la
sûreté pmp c'est vrai qu'on on a eu
plein de moments exceptionnels avec elle
oui vraiment et vous la regretter oui il
faut aussi qu'elle a marqué l'émission
et pourtant on n'a fait que 16 ans tout
comme rachid arhab à quoi l'a fait que
[Rires]
ces émissions
et comme vous l'aviez oublié voilà on
n'est pas monsieur comme on avait obligé
vous l'aviez obligé à bosser eh ben elle
était de mieux en mieux dans l'émission
honnêtement c'est même grâce à ça
qu'elle l'a vu après son certificat
d'études quand elle a vu dans cet
épisode wii ce qui pour m'amuser
car oui nico bien si l'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé
joyeux anniversaire à mon émission alors
ne regardez que s'adonner à ce qu'on a
eu des moments exceptionnels avec elle
et je voudrais dire moi vraiment je
l'aimais énormément
nabila et c'est restera mon ami pour
toujours c'est vrai monde a toujours été
avec elles mêmes voilà s'il ya eu des
petits moments difficiles on l'a
toujours soutenu regarde alors avec
celle au bout d'un large
on y a démoulez avec votre talon
attention le premier qui des moules
attention vous attendez mon top 2 3 des
moulins
vous voulez mais c'est pas parce que
c'est pas possible
généralement je le dois tout prix la
villa sarde et moules et franchement ça
vous pouvez l'écrire mille fois pour le
faire sont régalés hier que nabila qui
peut faire ça agace vous l'aimiez la
villa dans l'émission par les doors et
téléspectatrices de les visionner
j'adore j'adore vous avez à gérer
j'ai regretté quelques et
malheureusement les homologues
européennes mais j'adorerais vous êtes
l'accent belge la messe est célébrée
vous adoreriez oui mais j'aime beaucoup
bah merci pour sembler beaucoup à nana
mouskouri ce soir n'avaient pas les
cheveux plaqués je pense c'est vrai elle
est belle avait plus de volume mais
c'était une très belle femme
[Rires]